[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde l'autorité politique remise en
question l'autorité politique ne fait
pas recette de partout s'élèvent des
voix pour prenner des sociétés de
liberté de tolérance pluriculturelle
uvrant pour la diversité et le consensus
magnifiant le présent voire l'idolârant
et abrasant le passé bref du rêve pour
chacun de la prospérité pour tous et la
paix universelle en somme une modernité
Heuse qui ne s'embarrasserait ni des
contraintes intérieures les violences
les dégradations de service public
l'insécurité les précarités sociales et
financières et pas plus des aléas
extérieurs avec un enchaînement
conflictuel le terrorisme le covid la
guerre en Ukraine et de nous interroger
que peut le politique dans son essence
comme dans sa pratique face à ce qu'on
pourrait qualifier de démocratie si
malheureuse et de République tumultueuse
un politique dont les serviteurs n'ont
plus nom de Gaulle Churchill cléenceau
Mandela miteran margarette tcher Indira
Gandhi un politique qui cherche à plaire
en faisant de la communication l'art de
gouverner un politique s'exonérant de la
responsabilité et du courage de ces
actes pour éviter d'affronter une une
doxa bien pensante et bien souvent
éloignée des réalités nous examinerons
d'abord et surtout cette autorité
politique défaillante en France avec des
incursions ailleurs parce que partout il
y a une crise des idées et des valeurs
et partout les opinions et les
invectives font floress sur les réseaux
sociaux pour cette radiographie d'une
chute de l'autorité politique je vous
présente mes invités Vals vous êtes
ancien maire ancien député ancien
ministre ancien Premier ministre vous
nous direz ce que vous faites
aujourd'hui dans le présent anneel
Vergon vous êtes chef d'entreprise femme
politique puisque vous avez été
secrétaire adjointe à la présidence de
la République et présidente d'un fond
d'investissement ALP Nicolas bavrez vous
êtes avocat économiste politologue
chroniqueur au point et au Figaro Julien
Aubert ancien député vous êtes
vice-président vous voyez je vous ai
déjà promu vice-président de les
républicain et président de oser la
France un mouvement où se retrouvent
tous les
[Musique]
souverainistes après de Gaulle et le
phénomène s'est accentué depuis on fait
la distinction politique en entre servir
et habiter le pouvoir pour nous en tenir
à la France contemporaine et aux trois
dernières secous populairire et
politique les gilets jaunes la réforme
et la manif et les manifestations à
propos des retraites les révoltes de
jeunes avec toutes les violences
urbaines
occasionnées quel regard et quel
jugement portez-vous sur l'exercice du
pouvoir actuel en terme d'autorité
manuel Vals ou là vous commencez fort
cher Émile mal ah bah on est dans
l'actualité surtout surtout après après
le panorama qui porte essentiellement
sur la responsabilité politique que vous
avez présenté euh pour cette pour cette
émission tout pouvoir aujourd'hui dans
nos démocraties occidentales donc
celui-ci n'échappe pas à la règle
souffre d'une crise d'autorité elle est
sans doute plus aigue dans notre pays
pour des raisons sur lesquelles on
reviendra peut-être une nation
construite par l'État un État fort
centralisé euh une vision jacobine je
dirais de la société qui se sont
progressivement euh euh dégradés et je
rajoute à cela ce qui en fait aussi un
particularisme français pas seulement
mais avec un affaissement d'un système
politique en tout cas des des partis qui
avaient gouverné par alternance
notamment sous la 5e République euh et
donc une dégradation qui a laissé
un espace ouvert des nouvelles
formations politiques avec peu
d'implantations locales d'ailleurs pour
les plus importantes d'entre elles a
commencé par celle du président de la
République donc le président de la
République qui s'appuie sur une force
politique qui n'a pas d'histoire qui n'a
pas de mémoire qui n'a pas de racine qui
a eu les choses ont peut-être changé
mais qui a une certaine conception du
rôle ou de l'absence de rôle des cors
intermédiaire évidemment confronté à une
crise politique à une crise démocratique
à une crise
mon oui mais monsieur Vals permettez-moi
quand même de vous faire préciser
quelque chose vous avez été maire d'une
ville de banlieu les révoltes de ces
derniers temps ce sont des révoltes
populaires qui se sont déroulé bien sûr
dans les grande métropole mais aussi
dans les banlieux vous avez été ministre
de l'Intérieur et vous avez eu à gérer
la violence donc par rapport à ce qui
s'est passé en France est-ce que vous
considérez que l'autorité politique
s'est exprimé à l'occasion de ces
événements en général elle s'est
exprimée et vous évoquez sans doute
les les révoltes les émeutes les les
dégradations les mises en cause de
l'autorité publique de l'État avec des
dégradations de services publics d'écoes
de mairie de centres sociaux mais aussi
de commerce avec une très grande
violence à l'égard notamment des forces
de l'ordre moi j'ai le S sentiment que
après évidemment sans doute un moment
d'hésitation voir voir de de stupeur de
de surprise par rapport à ces violences
l'autorité politique côté police et côté
justice elle s'est exprimée par la
présence massive des force de police et
de gendarmerie et par les condamnations
qui ont eu lieu après mais sitôt passé
cet épisode les problèmes demeurent et
la contestation de cette autorité
politique et je dirais même d'une
certaine idée de la France puisque vous
citez le général de Gaulle euh parce que
moi je considère c'est à la fois une
manifestation contre l'autorité de
l'État mais aussi contre une forme de
vivre ensemble contre notre pays contre
ce qui fait France qui fait notre pays
pour utiliser des des des mots déjà très
utilisés donc un peu un peu un peu
dépassé mais c'est une manifestation de
de de haine très souvent à l'égard de
notre pays à laquelle nous avons assisté
c'est veut dire que les réponses euh euh
ell elles sont elles seront très
difficiles à trouver très lourdes mais
elles passent par une restauration et
l'autorité politique et aussi sur au
fond ce qui nous unit dans notre pays ce
qui fait que nous sommes Français Julien
Aubert vous êtes d'accord avec ça ou
vous pensez qu'il y a eu une défaillance
de l'autorité
politique sur la gestion euh de la
révolte des enfin c'est pas oui de
l'insurrection des banlieux et des
quartiers pour moi il y a eu il y a
quand même un aveu de faiblesse
c'est-à-dire que on a laissé en
partie brûler par peur du dérapage qui
pourrait nous amener sur une pente plus
délicate un peu comme pour les gilets
jaunes tant qu'il n'y a pas mort d'homme
j'avais l'impression que la la priorité
c'était d'éviter qu'on bascule dans
quelque chose de plus violent et en même
temps j'ai eu le sentiment que
l'autorité politique avait perdu un
moment le contrôle du territoire euh
d'ailleurs des unités de police qui ont
été réquisitionné l'ont été euh un peu à
la vite avec des unités qui étaient pas
forcément d'ailleurs on va dire formé
pour cela le raid notamment avec les
évidemment les conséquences que cela
peut engendrer lorsqu'ils se retrouvve à
faire un métier qui n'est pas le leur
puis après il y a je dirais deux sortes
d'autorités il y a évidemment euh la
capacité répressive et puis euh la
capacité à à faire peur parce que c'est
ce qui coûte le moins cher c'est-à-dire
que euh en réalité si on respecte le
pouvoir si on respecte la police on n
pas besoin d'exercer cette force ce qui
m'a inquiété c'est qu'on en est arrivé
au stade où on est obligé de mettre en
branle des forces armées la police la
gendarmerie avec le risque de
s'apercevoir que on est incapable de
tenir le terrain et pour répondre à
votre question euh que vous aviez posé à
Manuel Vals sur la question de la crise
de l'autorité moi je pense qu'il y a une
triple crise une crise de l'esprit une
crise de l'âme et une crise du physique
euh le physique c'est l'efficacité c'est
que les gens constatent qu'il y a des
problèmes et disent en réalité la
démocratie ne résout pas l'autorité
publique ne résout pas mes problèmes une
crise de l'esprit dans le sens où les
gens ne comprennent plus ou pas toujours
ou pas toujours très bien la manière
dont la démocratie fonctionne et en
vienent d'ailleurs à critiquer la maère
elle fonctionne par exemple l'usage du
493 et cetera et une crise de l'âme ce
qui est la plus je dirais la plus
profonde c'est que les gens ne croi plus
que la démocratie puisse répondre à
leurs problèmees ou ne croit plus que la
promesse républicaine de liberté de
l'égalité et la fraternité s'incarne
aujourd'hui et ces trois crises
conjuguées font que pour moi il y a
effectivement ce malaise qui ne se
limite pas aux révoltes de des quartiers
oui Ann lovergan vouliez intervenir
là-dessus je sais pas si je voulais
intervenir mais euh oui j'ai le
sentiment qu'effectivement on a une une
crise je dirais morale et puis après il
y a des problématiques très matérielles
et très pratiques pour savoir si
effectivement les forces de l'ordre al
la crise morale pour moi elle est assez
elle est assez française occidental hein
vous parliez au début de tous les pays
tas de pays où l'autorité
elle est pas vraiment légère donc ça
moufte pas ça ne bouge pas et justement
trouver le bon équilibre est très
complexe je crois que moi je reviendrai
sur un point tout le 19e siècle et une
grosse partie du 20e siècle jusque dans
les années 90 on a parlé du progrès tous
les politiques parlaient de progrès et
il y avait dans l'idée de faire société
ensemble l'idée que demain serait
effectivement globalement on sait bien
que individuellement c'était un peu plus
complexe mais que globalement on allait
vers on a substitué au mot de progrès le
mot innovation qui un peu en fond de
bohème il y a ceux qui réussissent puis
y a les autres voilà et je pense qu'il
faut qu'on essaie de refaire société
ensemble c'est-à-dire le progrès parler
de progrès bah c'est considéré que
demain sera meilleur or aujourd'hui on
envoie des messages sur demain qui sont
exactement inverses c'est les C anxiétés
le changement climatique et cetera donc
c'est une société qui est à la fois un
peu désespérée où toutes les préventions
ne sont pas forcément à l'œuvre et donc
où les crises prennent des aspects
extrêmement brutaux alors avec un état
alors politique est responsable bien sûr
mais je dirais que c'est beaucoup plus
complexe que ça avec un état qui pour
moi est un un peu en voie de bah dans le
même malaise avec bah un effritement de
l'État je dirais c'est-à-dire dire vous
regardez d'abord
l'état s'enlève des prérogatives très
régulièrement vous avez aujourd'hui une
centaine d'autorités indépendantes qui
régulent des choses aussi importantes
que l'énergie le
droit les moyens de presse la télévision
et cetera donc l'État a organisé une
forme d'impuissance en
laissant moi je je je me souviens de
Renaud deoî de saint-mar qui était
secrétaire général du gouvernement et
qui était ensuite vice-président du
Conseil d'État à chaque fois qu'il
voyait dans une annonce d'un prochain
conseil des ministres une nouvelle
autorité indépendante il disit le
démembrement de l'État je ne veux pas
assister à ça je me fermerai les
oreilles et c'est vrai que c'était à la
mode on l'a fait on l'a beaucoup fait et
on n pas réfléchi à ce que ça voulait
dire on a aussi un phénomène qui je
crois est est à l'œuvre commission de
déontologie pour le départ des
fonctionnaires bon bah ça veut dire que
euh si vous vous voulez partir dans une
entreprise et c'est le cas de plus en
plus tôt bah vous avez intérêt à partir
jeune et non pas à rester servir l'État
vous avez eu donc un appauvrissement de
la substance or on a besoin de faire une
énorme un énorme réforme de l'État une
énorme réforme de l'État on a besoin de
simplifier tout il y a une aspiration
très forte de tous les gens à avoir
effectivement un service meilleur pour
les impôts qu'il payent ou qu'il ne
payent pas et tout ça on a l'impression
que c'est en friche en jacher alors même
que la demande est extraordinaire forte
alors on a bien vu que la réponse de
court terme de du politique a été de
dire on va prendre des des cabinets
souvent anglos Saxon pour faire le
travail c'est pas satisfaisant en plus
c'est pas des cabinets internationaux
qui vont savoir ce que l'État doit
devenir donc il y a un énorme travail
sur nous-mêmes tout le monde le sait
tout le monde le sent il va falloir le
faire alors Nicolas bavres vous nous
direz ce que vous pensez de cet
enchaînement des conflits qu'il a eu en
France et qu'on considère quasiment
comme une normalité même si elle est
pathologique mais je voudrais aller plus
loin en plus avec vous en vous
demandant d'où vient cet affaiblissement
de l'autorité chez nos gouvernants
est-ce qu'à votre avis c'est un mésugage
constitutionnel c'est des institutions
socio-culturel sous influence voquiste
c'est la communication qui est
omniprésente partout
c'est la tyrannie des opinions et face à
cela un pouvoir politique qui est gelé
je crois qu'il faut enevenenir on l'a
déjà on l'a déjà mis en valeur à
l'ambiguité de cette notion d'autorité
qui avait été bien éclairé par par Anna
arent parce que quand on parle de crise
de l'autorité spontanément on on on
pense à l'insuffisance de l'ordre public
ou à l'insuffisance de la contrainte ou
ou ou du contrôle l'utor é normalement
c'est une obéissance qui est une
obéissance consentie et comme on l'a dit
ça envoie à des valeurs chez nous aux
valeurs de de la République vous
distinguez bien autorité autoritarisme
voilà et en face effectivement on a deux
notions contraire à l'autorité il y a la
violence et puis il y a
l'autoritarisme et qui peut aujourd'hui
prendre la forme soit d'extrémisme à
l'intérieur des des démocraties soit de
régime autoritaire et d'Empire
autoritaire dont on voit que aujourd'hui
ils ont de nouveau une une agressivité
extrême contre contre la démocratie
alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en
fait on a dans l'ensemble du monde
démocratique les démocraties ont fait
une énorme erreur après le
l'effondrement de l'Union soviétique on
a pensé que c'était la victoire pour
l'éternité de la démocratie de
l'économie de marché les illusions de la
fin de l'histoire et derrière il y a
toute une série de chocs qui ont
déstabilisé profondément les nations
libres donc que il y a eu 2001 les
guerres en lisé perdu de l'Afghanistan
jusqu'au Sahel le craque de 2008 ensuite
la crise de l'euro les pandémies tout ça
ça partout on voit que ça a créé un ça a
déstabilisé la classe moyenne et ça crée
un énorme désordre il suit de voir aux
États-Unis précisément normalement aux
États-Unis le fondement de l'autorité
c'est que on croit à la Constitution et
on croit au vote oui mais en face le
vous trouvez que le pouvoir politique
fait son boulot bah très clairement aux
États-Unis non seulement le pouvoir
politique ne fait pas son travail mais
Donald Trump est un agent de destruction
massive de ce qui a été euh l'ordre et
et l'autorité politique aux États-Unis
qui est aux États-Unis l'autorité c'est
la Constitution et donc à partir du
moment où on a un président qui a été
élu maintenant un candidat qui de
manière frontale remet en cause et la
constitution et le vote là le le le en
l'occurrence c'est une force politique
qui participe de la déstabilisation donc
en tout cas on a ça partout en France on
a une situation et la France reste une
situation exceptionnelle pour les
raisons qui ont été décrites parce que
la France elle est particulièrement
vulnérable quand on voit les hauts et
les bas depuis
1789 comme la Révolution a mis en en en
face l'État et le citoyen il y a pas de
société civile entre les deux quand
l'État est bien géré et va bien que le
citoyen est prospère le système
fonctionne bien quand on commence à
avoir des chocs et que l'État devient
obèse et impuissant d'un côté que le
citoyen est totalement désorienté là ça
dysfonctionne et donc on a bien ce
problème ce double problème de
l'efficacité donc un état obèse et
impuissant il récupère 58 % du PIB mais
il n'est plus capable de produire ni de
la santé ni de l'éducation ni de la
police ni de la justice ni des
transports dans des
conditions ENF d'efficacité correcte
pour la population et il y a derrière le
problème des le problème des valeurs et
ce que vous avez rappelé quand même
parce qu'on peut rajouter l' épisode que
vous avez directement connu euh et qui
est évidemment gravissime les attentats
de 2015 le fait qu'on a une partie de
euh de la des des de la population qui
vit sur le territoire et une partie euh
des Français qui ne se reconnaissent
plus dans les lois de de de la
République ensuite on a eu les gilets
jaunes les manifestations contre les
retraites les émeutes urbaines donc on
voit très bien que aujourd'hui j'allais
dire chacun fait sa loi alors pour les
uns euh c'est la loi religieuse pour les
autres c'est la loi euh euh des gang euh
et et et des bandes euh pour les trisèm
c'est la loi de des des communautés mais
de fait et ça c'est une crise qui est
une crise vous voyez c'est la vraie
crise de l'autorité c'est-à-dire que ça
veut pas dire qu'il y a pas d'autorité
mais l'autorité ça peut être l'imam
l'autorité ça peut
être le chef de gang l'autorité et ça
n'est plus une autorité qui est une
autorité collective et reconnue al sur
cette autorité
déconstruite avec une violence qui est
là quasiment permanente manuel Vals
qu'est-ce que vous pensez par
Jean-Pierre leof dans un sociologue dans
un essai récent qui s'appelle Les Années
Folles à propos de Mai 68 met en cause
le gauchisme culturel en disant qu'il
est essentiellement violent et niiliste
est-ce qu'on peut faire une comparaison
entre cette violence là et la violence
qui a eu en France ces derniers temps
dans les banlieux et dans les métropoles
parce que ça s'est exprimé avec de la
violence oui mais il y a des il y a des
éléments qui que nous partageons avec
les grandes démocraties occidentales du
monde libre etve qui nous partageons des
valeurs communes et nous avons subi les
uns et les les uns et les autres à peu
près les mêmes chocs gr les effets de la
globalisation économique pour pour aller
vite et qui s'accentue avec le rôle et
le pouvoir des gsfemmes le sentiment au
fond pour les citoyens euh que on perd
le le pouvoir démocratique qui s'exerce
dans chaque nation et puis il y a des
éléments de perte d'autorité que là
aussi on retrouve un peu partout je je
fais vite mais euh l'autorité du parent
des parents l'autorité du professeur
alors peut-être que cela vient de
mouvement de fond de la société qu'on
peut imputer même s'il y a aussi des
effets positifs de mai de Mai 68 pour
mais chez nous cette crise de l'autorité
est profondément liée pas seulement et
c'est une différence avec d'autres pays
où l'État est peu présent avec une crise
de l'État et de son efficacité et je ne
refais pas la liste ou sinon je la
refais fait qui était rappelé il y a un
instant santé
école police énergie transport les
Français ont le sentiment que pour être
trivial tout faut le camp et le lien de
l'autorité politique est à faire avec la
crise de l'autorité de l'État si vous
rajoutez à cela d'ailleurs dans les que
vous m'interrogez compris sur le
président actuel derrière avec des
contradiction d'ailleurs mais on remet
en cause l'enat on remet en cause euh le
rôle des préfets on remet en cause le
corps des cors constitués le corps
diplomatique donc les corps constitués
même si à l'intérieur ça ne change pas
forcément beaucoup le le message qui
passe c'est qu'on continue à effriter
cette autorité de l'État moi je pense
que le rôle du politique il est de pas
se laisser entraîner c'est facile à dire
surtout quand on est plus dans
l'exercice du pouvoir moi j'ai le
sentiment parfois que le pouvoir
m'échappait et dans d'autres occasions
que par le verbe par l'action notamment
face aux attentats terroristes on
pouvait évidemment agir souvent le
politique arrive à agir en temps de
crise c'est là d'une certaine manière il
a la réponse à court terme mais sur le
moyen surtout sur le long terme c'est là
où il
estise novergon moi je voudrais rebondir
là-dessus parce que je crois que le un
gros défaut du politique aujourd'hui et
de ne pas savoir anticiper les crises je
prends un sujet que je connais un petit
peu l'
j'ai sonné le toxin un peu partout en
septembre 2021 il était parfaitement
clair qu'on allait devant une crise
énergétique grave pour l'hiver que
n'igje
entendu à tout niveau de l'État ça soit
dans les administrations ou dans le
monde politique c'était vraiment une
vision catastrophiste et cetera ou il y
avait une pression de l'opinion des
veres contre le nucléaire je parlais pas
de nucléaire je disais on va vers une
crise énergétique il faut faut faire ce
qu'on fait les Espagnols et les
Portugais dans un mécanisme très malin
et qui leur a permis effectivement de
faire beaucoup d'économie et de protéger
leurs
citoyens d'abord faire comme les
espagnols et portugais très franchement
c'est pas digne des français et non
c'était je n'entends rien je n'entends
rien avant d'être devant le sujet moi ce
qui me frappe beaucoup dans cet
effritement c'est la perte des sachants
c'est-à-dire que sur des sujets je
reprends l'énergie mais je pourra en
prendre plein d'autres il y avait dans
le système étatire des sachants il y a
30 ans Jean sirota directeur général de
l'énergie des matières premières je peux
vous assurer que il avait une batterie
de gens qui avait des opinions qui
pouvaient être différentes de celle de
DF ou d'autres mais il y avait des
corpus et un suivi là aujourd'hui vous
diriez la même chose vous diriez la même
chose du fait que les derniers prix
Nobel ces deux dernières années français
travaillent à l'étranger bah ça c'est
aussi le ridicule de
d'indiquer une date de retraite pour
tout le monde queles que soient les
conditions et en particulier à 60 ans
enfin c'est absurde ENF c'est l'idée
qu'effectivement à partir d'un certain
âge on est plus productif donc on peut
vous jeter donc vous dire à quel point
sur des sujets essentiels qui sont
vraiment des sujets de de l'État nation
vous diriez jusqu'à on a laissé
abandonner alors je vous donne un exès
est-ce que vous diriez que les
politiques sont émasculés du savoir du
hautir
grand sair dans un certain nombre de cas
il y a une organisation qui s'est mise
en place qui leur enlève la possibilité
de savoir suffisamment tôt pour prévenir
je vous donne un exemple très concret là
aussi lié à l'énergie pendant des
dizaines d'années pas ctier le général
de Gaulle mais ça existait bien avant
lui il y avait des services du ministère
de l'Industrie qui prévoyit les
consommations énergétiques de la France
à long terme et qui essayait de voir si
la demande des l'offre pourrait se
rencontrer et bien aujourd'hui ça n'est
plus l'état qui le fait c'est une
filiale de
DF l'État n'a plus de position sur un
sujet aussi majeur alors vous prenez
c'est RTE qui fait ça alors vous avez en
2021 il sortent des prévisions qui sont
entièrement différentes de celles de
2023 dans un cas il fallait réduire
totalement la production et la
consommation maintenant il fautugment
veut dire un mot là-dessus oui peut-être
que le fait que RTE se dirigeait par un
ancien du président de la République
explique cela mais je je je je suis
d'accord avec le le fait qu'il y a la
perte des sachants la perte d'expertise
maintenant dans une crise d'autorité
c'est comme une paire de ciseaux il y a
deux volets il y a effectivement une
crise de l'état de son mode
d'organisation le fait d'assumer la
responsabilité et d'être capable d'avoir
une vision prospective et puis il y a
une crise de société en face parce que
là on a on a fait une expérience grande
en nature avec les réseaux sociaux je
crois que l'humain
qui est à la fois citoyen avec un
certain nombre de règles et qui la
moitié du temps est sur un espace
numérique parfaitement horizontale où il
y a pas de règles pas d'obligation pas
de responsabilité pas
d'individualisation et où finalement
c'est un peu une loi de la jungle ben ça
finit par rétro-agir sur la société
Julien Aubert je voudrais vous poser une
question très personnelle si vous
permettez je dirais que vous êtes un
politique qui vient du sud parce que
vous êtes un élu un élu du vooclus OUI
comment vous expliquez cette
contradiction de l'électorat qui est
plus tenté par voter pour des hommes
farouchement ou des femmes farouchement
engagées comme Marine Le Pen ou Jean-Luc
Mélanchon plutôt que pour des politiques
qui sont modérés mais qui sont en même
temps rigoureux dans leur gestion de la
société vous en tant que appartenant au
mouvement les républicains et même sur
vos terres vos clus
vous aviez des positions qui étaient
très affirmées or vous avez été battu
par plus extrême que vous comment vous
expliquez cette contradiction j'ai été
battu par quelqu'un de la majorité donc
je sais pas si soit plus extrême que moi
mais oui oui mais parce qu'il y a eu à
côté parce qu'il y a eu une vague
d'abord parce qu' y il y a des
phénomènes de vagu et
d'étiquettes avec une colère je pense
populaire et un
divorce étant donné qu'il y a eu des
crises démocratiques avant il y a eu des
séismes démocratiques ce qui s'est passé
en 2005 avec un référendum européens où
les les Français ont voté à 55 % contre
un traité et ensuite les élus ont
détricoté n'a pas je dirais enclencher
un mécanisme de confiance de la part de
des gens qui avaient voté non et
d'ailleurs ces gens qui avaient voté non
quand vous prenez la sociologie c'était
plutôt des gens issus des classes
populaires des classes des classes les
les plus les moins les moins riches vous
retrouvez ensuite par exemple l ce qui
s'est passé aux élections
présidentielles avec le front
républicain les électeurs de Marine Le
Pen sont structurellement plutôt des
électeurs effectivement venant des
classes populaires il y a le sentiment
d'une dépossession de dire les élus ont
fait cause commune pour m'empêcher de
gagner pour m'empêcher de de d'exprimer
aussi la souffrance qui est la mienne et
d'Illes il y avait eu un sondage très
intéressant qui montrait que 80 % des
électeurs de Marine Le Pen considérait
qu'il n'était pas heureux dans la vie
qu'il menait ou qu'il leur manquait des
choses donc je dirais il y a à mon avis
on a utilisé parfois la démocratie
contre la démocratie ça n'aide pas aussi
à comprendre la manière dont ça
fonctionne et deuxièmement le sentiment
d'une partie du pays que quelque part
les décisions sont prises par d'autres
et que on a faussé les le jeu
démocratique pour les empêcher à un
moment donné de faire entendre leur
revendication et tout ça se focalise sur
des partis effectivement protestataires
qui deviennent des partis où
d'identification de de victimisation en
disant je suis mal dans mon système et
je vote pour le parti qui finalement est
mis écart
[Musique]
ou vous venez de voir la citation
d'Henry Kissinger alors Nicolas bavrez
est-ce que nos hommes politiques
manquent-il de caractère et est-ce que
c'est lié ce manque de caractère à une
méconnaissance de l'histoire il me
souvient qu'enri Kissinger disait
d'Obama qu'il n'avait pas ce recul de
l'histoire bah vous savez c'est raaymond
Aaron qui avait critiqué justement
Valérie giscardestin en lui disant que
navait pas le sens du du tragique de
l'histoire quand il était allé discuter
avec
bregneev exactement au lendemain de de
l'invasion de de l'Afghanistan en fait
le tragique de l'histoire si vous voulez
d'une certaine manière on on est plus
que servi et et je crois qu'il faut
quand même rappeler la difficulté de ce
qui est de gouver aujourd'hui quand on
regarde le nombre de chocs donc on a une
crise sanitaire qui se poursuit quand
même on a une crise énergétique on a une
crise alimentaire on a l'inflation qui
redémarre et une crise monétaire on a
une crise stratégique et une crise
climatique donc évidment fa le caractère
c'est le contraire de la versatilité et
et là-dedans il faut effectivement
essayer de de de tracer de tracer un
chemin et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui ce
qui frappe quand même c'est que il y en
a qui arrivent quand même ou qui qui le
dessinent je prendrai l'exemple des
États-Unis aujourd'hui la société est en
état de quasi guerre civile mais ils ont
inventé l'IRA donc cette machine à
subventionné qui est derrière il y a une
vraie ligne stratégique pour le coup
puisque c'est je
réindustrialise je fais la transition
climatique et je me sers de tout ça pour
restabiliser la classe moyenne est-ce
que ça va fonctionner ou pas on verra
mais au moins il y a une idée et puis à
l'extérieur l'idée c'est que maintenant
la rivalité est avec la Chine et que on
va utiliser la technologie pour
dissuader la Chine et garder l'avantage
militaire bon quand on prend l'Europe du
Nord on a aussi parce que il y a quand
même des endroits en Europe et des
démocraties qui vont pas si mal quand on
regarde la Suède la stratégie zéro
fossile quand on regarde la Norvège
c'est des pays qui ont réussi avec des
tensions fortes he y compris sur le plan
migratoire mais à comment à trouver des
formules où le citoyen se sent quand
même toujours engagé dans un projet
national on a de la compétitivité on a
de la transition et on a une certaine
forme de stabilité politique et une
capacité aussi à remettre en cause
beaucoup de choses puisque la Suède
intègre l'OTAN ce qui était à priori
pour le coup c'est des siècles de
neutralité
qui qui sont remises en en question donc
ce qui manque aujourd'hui en revanche
effectivement dans un pays comme la
France c'est qu'on a euh c'est la
fameuse j'allais dire je pense que c'est
la meilleure formule qui a été utilisée
celle de Fourquet sur l'archipel
français en fait cette archipelllisation
du pays elle vaut pour la société elle
vaut pour l'économie elle vaut pour
toutes les société démocratique elle
vaut pour le système oui mais il y en a
vous voyez qui qui on commencai à
essayer de de reconstruire ou d'essayer
de de retisser des de retisser des fils
et c'est vrai que comme il a été dit
nous on a le on a sur les deux bout du
système puisque chez nous il y a peu de
société civile l'état aujourd'hui est
impuissant il est surendetté et puis il
y a une extrême confusion quand même
regardez ce dont on a parlé bon si on
parle d'éducation ensuite on peut
trouver des mérites penser ce qu'on veut
mais on peut pas le même président de la
République ne peut pas avoir comme comme
même ministre monsieur Blanquer et
Monsieur nia quand on prend le nucléaire
on peut pas expliquer qu'on ferme
fenheim et puis ensuite redécouvrir que
finalement non non on arrête de fermer
parce qu' cont on va prolonger parce que
finalement le et on vous voyez quand on
regarde l'essentiel on peut pas
commencer à discuter pendant 6 mois avec
Poutine pour dire qu'ensuite on est avec
les ukrainiens et qu'on va accélérer
leur rentrée dans l'Union européenne il
y a pas un thème parce que chez nous
l'impulsion du haut elle est quand même
importante et il y a pas un thème sur
lequel le président de la République n'a
pas dit tout est son
contraire mais ça ça n'est pas sa seu
responsabilité que dit Nicolas bavrez
mais sans l'exprimer ce que disent les
Chinois le poisson pourr par la tête
j'ai vu plutôt une critique en même
temps non mais exactement je pense que
en même temps c'est un slogan électoral
génial mais ça ne permet pas ni de
présider ni de gouverner et il y a
l'autre dimension qui a été rappelé qui
est l'anomie de P entier du territoire
de la population et ça c'est 40 ans de
déclin économique et social donc
évidemment mais aujourd'hui ça prend une
dimension jeis dire pathologique vous
vouliz dire un mot non je je pense que
ce que chacun dit c'est que et et en
France on on le voit peut-être davantage
mais c'est cette contradiction ce choc
entre la verticalité compris incarné par
nos institutions et par l'attente du
rôle de l'État et l'horizontalité de nos
sociétés accéléré par les réseaux
sociaux et que dire demain de
l'intelligence artificielle avec un
paradoxe parce que ça frappe toutes les
sociétés c'est que cela ne produit pas
forcément plus de démocratie cela peut
produire plus de confusion et peut
amener à l'autoritarisme vous voyez
partout c'était le cas de Trump mais des
phénomènes comme my en Argentine où sur
la base de la désinformation véhiculée
par ces réseaux sociaux on va vers des
candidatures ou des élections de
personnages très antiémocratiques très
illibéraux et en tout cas qui remettent
en cause les les systèmes je je veux
quand même parce qu'on peut décrire à
foison les sociétés dans lesquel nous
sommes et je je partage les analyses qui
ont été apportées jusqu'ici c'est
quelles sont les les solutions alors moi
je crois beaucoup à la stratégie à long
terme je prendrai un autre exemple où le
pouvoir politique acculé a été obligé de
faire un virage sur l'aile massif on
verra quels sont les résultats c'est
l'Allemagne qui qui en quelques mois est
obligé de changer de de stratégie
énergétique la dépendance au gaz et et
au pétrole russe et d'avoir une autre
vision stratégique dans son rapport
militaire avec sa propre histoire c'est
tout à fait considérable ce qui se passe
ils vont réussir sans doute avec du
temps avec beaucoup de difficultés ils
n'ont pas les mêmes problèmes
budgétaires et financiers que les nres
donc ils ont des marges de manœuvre
qu'il vont pouvoir utiliser mais c'est
un changement et si je veux rester
optimiste ce changement stratégique nous
a imposé à nous aussi et français et et
européen au fond la crise pandémique et
la crise énergétique et la crise
stratégique c'estàd la guerre en Ukraine
nous oblige nous français et européens à
changer et et et là ça nous oblige à des
à des à des choix qui sont massifs en
matière de dépenses militaire en matière
d'autonomie ou d'indépendance
énergétique mais aussi industriel donc
les investissements massifs qu'il faut
faire en terme de semi-conducteur ou de
batterie nous oblige à des changements
mais du coup il faut l'expliquer et moi
je crois c'est peut-être ça la crise de
l'âme et et ce qu'on peut reprocher au
pouvoir actuel mais mais mais mais
peut-être aussi au pouvoir passé c'est
de ne pas indiquer le cap stratégique
c'est de ne pas dire où nous allons
c'estd le poids le poids par exemple de
la guerre en Ukraine pour moi c'est un
sujet de réflexion et d'action je
comprends pas qu'on y revienne pas sans
cesse parce que ça va nous nous allons
vivre avec avec des conséquences très
importante or on est et la parole de ce
point de vue-l alors c'est un autre
sujet la parole du président de la
République devrait se concentrer sur
l'essentiel et non pas être dispersé en
permanence entre des annonces sur le
plan énergétique qui appartiennent
plutôt à la première ministre ou sur des
brigades de gendarmerie c'est des sujets
très importants mais la parole
présidentielle et donc politique devrait
se concentrer sur les trois quatre
sujets essentiels qui fond de notre
avenir et notre oui alors moi j'aimerais
bien que vous nous disiez Anel vergeon
si cette contradiction qui vient d'être
évoquée là entre sur les choix essentiel
du pays c'est disons ces 20 dernières
années on a dit une chose et son
contraire comment voulez-vous que les
gens adèrent alors moi moi je dirais je
dirais plusieurs choses le en même temps
effectivement c'est une idée assez
séduisante parce que on est tous un peu
ambivalent c'est-à-dire qu'on veut une
chose et on en veut une autre donc on
peut être ambigé ambiguité ambivalence
hein voilà ambigué ambivalence ça fait
partie aussi ça flatte le sujet c'est
qu'on est face à un certain nombre de
problèmes qui doivent être pris avec
énormément de
rationalité on a passé les 20 dernières
années à dire que l'industrie finalement
c'était quelque chose de sale de d'un
intéressant que finalement il suffisait
de concevoir et on était tellement plus
intelligent que les autres faire du
marketing on est tellement meilleur et
puis on irait en délocalisant très loin
qu'importe les emplois qu'importe le
reste on se réveille grgy et on dit ah
bah tiens il faudrait
réindustrialiser je pense qu'il y a une
forme de consensus sur la
réindustrialisation aujourd'hui après
avoir eu un consensus
antiindustrie et après avoir d'ailleurs
suivi l'Allemagne sur tous ces aements
énergétiques et cetera on on il y a une
culpabilité générale mais sur la
réindustrialisation elle suppose une
chose très simple elle suppose deux
choses très simples c'est d'avoir de
l'énergie pas chère compétitive or vous
prenez la Suède vous prenez la Finlande
ils sont aujourd'hui à 15 € le MWh on
est à combien aujourd'hui là ici en
France
90 or il fait beau euh il y a aucune
raison qu'on soit à ce prix-là et les
futures pour cet hiers sont monstrueux
ça veut dire que la compétitivité de
l'État français pour une
réindustrialisation n'est pas là donc le
premier sujet c'est comment on va
retrouver une énergie pas chère on ne
s'y attaque absolument pas deuxième
sujet pour faire de l'industrie il faut
des matières premières c'est la paliss
serurait pu le dire où sont les matières
premières où sont nos groupes miners où
sont nos capacités
a effectivement sourcer ces matières
premières on n jamais autant parleré
méga usine de batterie mais c'est méga
usin de batterie on va les remplir avec
quoi les métor rares ils viennent d'où
donc on est on se nourrit de mots on se
nourrit de mots on est très heureux on
est
réindustrialisation fantastique et il y
a rien derrière c'est-à-dire que le
travail en amont que font formidablement
bien les pays nordiques mais des tas
d'autres endroits dans le monde l'IRA
c'est ça aussi au États-Unis c'est
réfléchir à l'essentiel c'est-à-dire
dire on veut le on veut palier le
changement climatique on veut la
réindustrialisation on veut des emplois
en France comment va-t-on y arriver dans
un monde compétitif et bien ça ça
suppose un S de chose ça suppose des
technologie aussi ça suppose
l'innovation tous ces
élémentsl des ressources humaines tous
élé les mettre en route justement Julien
Aubert par rapport à ce qui vient d'être
dit là à votre avis d'où vient cette
versatilité politique qui empêche de
faire des choix clairs de changer tous
les 10 ans de politique et cetera est-ce
que c'est un manque de caractère est-ce
que c'est parce que les gens ne ces
politiques ne connaissent pas l'histoire
est-ce qu'ils sont euh ils déclassent
les corps constitués et cetera à quoi
vous attribuez justement d' il y a il y
a une part d'idéologie euh je dire
lorsque disait qu'il y a une idéologie
oiseuse conse lorsqu'on décide de fermer
de de changer l'enat lorsqu'on décide de
de décréter que les diplomates doivent
plus être un corps à part lorsque on
décide d'ouvrir les postes de préfet à
je dirais pour faire un espèce de marché
libre avec la possibilité d'aller et de
venir tout ceci procède pour moi d'une
idéologie il se trouve que c'est pas la
mienne parce que je pense que l'État ça
se pense et ça se pense par des gens qui
aiment l'État et qui savent pourquoi
l'État est là et c'est pas je moi je ne
me pique pas en tant que fonctionnaire
de réfléchir à la manière dont une
entreprise doit fonctionner je ne suis
pas légitime ça veut pas dire que j'ai
pas mon point de vue je peux avoir un
point de vue externe mais l'état ça
n'est pas une entreprise ça ne peut pas
fonctionner comme une entreprise c'est
trop important pour qu'on le pense comme
une entreprise donc premè il y a pas de
on ne pense pas l'état on ne pense plus
l'état on le pense de l'extérieur donc
il y a une part d'idéologie deuxièmement
il y a il y a un manque de conviction
c'est qu'à un moment donné effectivement
ça n'est pas qu'une affaire d'intuition
aussi la politique c'est aussi arbitrer
à partir de on demande pas un homme
politique d'être omniscient mais on lui
demande quand même d'être suffisamment
informé de peser le pour et le contre et
de trancher des choix en ayant
effectivement une stratégie ça
supposerait aussi de rebattir des outils
pour penser temporellement et
géographiquement parce que la 25 ans de
mondialisation on fait que on voit pas
la mondalisation de la même manière à
Toulouse ù en a abus et en vauluse où
l'agriculture a été laminée par
l'ouverture au marché espagnol et
marocain et puis enfin il y a
effectivement la difficulté queon a tous
pointé qui est que bah on a une partie
de la population qui ne vote plus une
partie de la donc qui ne consent plus
une partie de la population qui est
protestataire et d'où la tentation de de
de d'essayer de regrouper ce qui reste
et le en même temps est aussi une
tentative de créer une espèce de de de
tiers qui pourrait permettre
d'équilibrer le navire parce qu'on est
peut-être d'accord sur un certain nombre
de points il en reste pas moin qu'à un
moment donné on doit trancher et je
pense que effectivement ça a été la
grande faiblesse du président du
président actuel on pourrait dire de
manière positive qu'on a tous un jour
été d'accord avec Emmanuel Macron ou
qu'on le sera très sincèrement très
sincèrement Julien Aubert est-ce que
vous pensez que Jacques Chirac tranchait
plus qu'Emmanuel Macron je pense qu'il
je alors je l'ai un peu moins connu je
pense qu'il de ce que vous savez de
cette histoire je pense qu'il a pris
parfois des positions très structurantes
petit nombre après c'est pas le
Président si vous voulez qui pour moi
euh je dirais a permis d'accélérer
l'entrée de la France dans l'histoire ou
sa réintroduction c'est que c'est pas
mon modèle à moi de de de présidence
parce que Sarkozy c'est plus votre
modèle bah au moins Nicolas Sarkozi a
tenté de de faire des choses certes il a
déçu par certains endroits mais
notamment dans la crise il a pris en
main le pays et je pense qu'il a évité
pendant la crise financière que ça
s'aggrave il a fait des choses il a a
tenté d'impulser une volonté politique
ce qui est grave c'est quand vous avez
une forme de de tentative de surtout on
ne touche rien on met des rustines pour
que ça tienne encore un peu sauf qu'au
bout d'un moment la machine elle perd
des boulons elle perd des écrous et le
coût final de la réparation du véhicule
ch le garagiste d'accord mais enfin vous
voyez sur le nucléaire Emmanuel Macron a
pris la bonne décision au moins làdus il
a fini par la prendre mais enfin B oui
mais prédécesseurs n'avait pas fait
mieux non non ah non non sur les sur les
prédécesseurs il y a eu effectivement
sur fermeture de super Phenix qui était
une erreur maintenant rien rien
n'incitait monsieur Macron à fermer le
programme Astrid de 4e génération rien
ne l'obliga à continuer la faute qui
avait été faite sur Fessenheim rien ne
l'obligé à annoncer la fermeture d'un
certain nombre de centrale nucléairirees
sans savoir vérifi sans avoir vérifié si
on avait je dirais les moyens de
compenser et et tout ceci on le on
l'avait annoncé bien avant puisquon
l'avait annoncé dès le quinqu avant donc
il a fini effectivement une extrémist
par faire un tête à queue reste que si
aujourd'hui la filière est dans cet état
il a une partie de responsabilité pas la
totalité parce que Nicolas bavz voulait
dire quelque chose làdus oui je crois
que si vous vouz sur le diagnostic on
est à peu près tous d'accord
c'est-à-dire que le pouvoir actuel il
est mu par trois choses la peur depuis
les gilets jaunes et on le voit avec la
poursuite ce que vous appelez la les
dépenses qui sont faites pour essayer de
de colmater dès qu'on a une protestation
l'impuissance parce que les mots n'ont
plus de prise sur les choses et puis le
le le troème point c'est effectivement
le j'allais dire le la rupture avec la
connaissance ça a été dit avec la
science ça ça s'est vu par exemple
pendant la pandémie de manière
incroyable et on compense ça en faisant
des conseils de défense sanitaire ce qui
n'ont aucun sens parce que on a abîmé la
le conseil de défense et on l'pplique le
conseil de défense à la à l'écologie au
sanitaire bon alors voilà le
diagnosticque on est à peu près tous
d'accord la vraie bonne question c'est
celle que posait manuel Vals voilà c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors justement
qu'est-ce qu'on fait il me semble que
d'abord deè une deuxème émission non non
mais pour aller vite il y a quand même
ou parce qu'il nous reste très peu temps
on va aller très vite on parle de
réforme des institution et de de
référendum la 5e République elle a quand
même été faite pour gérer les crises
mais elle est faite pour gérer les
crises avec un système qui a un système
militaire la stratégie est à l'Élysée
l'opératif est à matigon le tactique est
dans les ministères on a tout fait
remontter à l'ésée ça peut pas marcher
donc il faut et si on veut aussi pouvoir
associer les citoyens il faut retrouver
l'esprit de la 5e République et remettre
des contrepouvoirs parce que si on ne
discute pas des choses si ça vient
toujours du haut ça ne marche pas la
deuxième chose pour les citoyens enfin
la 5e République c'était aussi une
monarchie républicaine he c'était aussi
tout était en haut quand même tout
n'était pas en haut non non quand on
regarde les premiers ministres de du
général de Gaulle ils ont eu des des des
vraies marches de manœuvre et je
rappelle que le le nucléaire c'est
beaucoup Pierre Messmer qui n'était pas
président de de la République les
ministres du général de Gaulle avaient
une vraie marche de manœuvre c'est pas
le général de Gaulle qui nommait à tous
les emplois et la deuxième chose la plus
pour le c'est il faut qu'on se concentre
sur quelques priorités ça a été dit la
production donc la réindustrialisation
l'énergie l'éducation
la sécurité bref avoir et et pour les
citoyens je c'est cette dernière chose
qui me paraît très importante on l'a dit
le l'autorité c'est une obéissance qui
est consentie et donc si on veut que les
gens croient à la liberté il faut qu'ils
aient été éduqués à la liberté et qu'ils
en comprennent aussi les responsabilités
sinon on a l'emballement des pass c'est
faisable dans une société
pluriculturelle mais bien sûr c'est
c'est c'est faisable quand on prend
l'Europe du Nord là encore ils y
arrivent ces chantiers parce que je suis
d'accord avec euh l'ensemble des
priorités qu'il faut développer
puisqu'il faut et la vôtre comme choc de
rupture l'immigration c'estàdire que
j'ai j'ai c'est un peut-être un des
derniers champs sur lequel les français
espèrent oui manuel Val une précision
vous êtes pour par exemple la politique
danoise de suppression de l'attractivité
à l'immigration plutôt plutôt plutôt
même si c'est évidemment euh je suis je
suis pour un pour pour un un message
clair qui dire stop à une forme
d'immigration on remet tout le chantier
sur sur la table et on fait participer
les Français à cette décision ça a
beaucoup de conséquences elles sont
constitutionnelles et Europe politique
mais je pense que c'est un des champs
qui touche à peu près euh toutes les
tous les difficultés sur lesemarc on a
bien les deux on a le contrôle des flux
et l'intégration et l'intégration et
donc évidemment c'est à la fois dire non
repenser notre politique d'immigration
mais aussi repenser la question de l'âme
et et de l'esprit qui est qu'est-ce que
c'est être français c'est la question de
l'assimilation et pour répondre à l'une
des crises qu'on a évoqué tout à l'heure
donc et c'est un des derniers éléments
sur lesquels les Français se disent là
il y a y compris des bases d'un
consensus ou plutôt d'un accord
majoritaire dans notre pays à condition
qu'on le veuille bien c'est je pense un
des rendez-vous majeurs qui démontrerait
que l'action politique est encore
possible et le deuxième élément c'est le
choix stratégique d'ailleurs un des
éléments qui montre que le politique
utile hein c'est quoi le choix
stratégique bah écoutez quand vous avez
volodimir Zelenski vous avez un homme
qui a un moment précis par le verbe et
par la manière d'être remobilise son
peuple nous ne sommes pas en guerre mais
cela veut bien dire que ce qui se passe
en Ukraine et ce qui se passe avec la
Russie est pour nous tout à fait
fondamental alors choc de rupture Julien
Aubert sur
l'immigration sur l'Ukraine d'ailleurs
vous nous direz ce que vous pensez de la
position monsieur Sarkozi sur l'Ukraine
moi je trouve que Nicolas Sarkozi a eu
raison de s'exprimer suréta de son avis
ça faisait très longtemps que j'avais
pas été de son avis mais je pense qu'il
a une vision lucide est réaliste de la
manière dont on dont on doit aborder le
conflit ukrainien et on n'est pas là
pour si vous voulez c'estàdire on laisse
une Russie impériale non on on comprend
qu'il y a un rapport de force et on
comprend qu'à un moment donné la
priorité de mettre un terme à ce conflit
et que on ne le fera pas tout le monde
le souhaite en ne prenant qu'un un seul
des deux camps et en considérant on n
pas on n'est pas dans le monde dans
lequel on devrait être on est dans le
monde dans lequel on est maintenant
il faut pour moi mettre fin au
fédéralisme européen et au au lubi du
couple franco-allemand et Madame Van
derleyen revoit la décentralisation qui
a complètement déresponsabilisé les élus
locaux remettre de la responsabilité
politique ça va du du du président de la
République jusqu'au maire mais il faut
je dirais restaurer le le pouvoir des
maires de telle manière si vous voulez à
ce que un moment donné on remet la
maison d'aplon et puis après
effectivement il y a j'imagine que vous
êtes d'accord sur l'immigration avec
manuel et sur l'école voilà et sur
l'école an lovergeon votre choc de
rupture pour avancer expliciter un petit
nombre de sujets parce qu'il faut
hiérarchiser les problèmes or là on est
dans la dispersion la plus
totale un certain nombre un petit nombre
de sujets dont on a parlé ce soir les
après cette hiérarchisation discuter de
plans de long terme retrouver le temps
long et faire que ceci soit adopté de
manière collective pour qu'on puisse un
ministre du Plan par exemple un ministre
du Plan n'a aucun pouvoir d'c tout ça
doit venir
effectivement les ministres du plan ils
n'ont plus de pouvoir en France depuis
hé beaucoup d'années non il faut
retrouver le sens du temps long et le
sens de la
stratégie il faut qu'on joue nos cartes
et on les joue pas bien en ce moment
parce que on est brouillon parce qu'on
change d'avis parce qu'on a pas le sens
de de la stratégie donc retrouvonsla et
et et et regardons ce qui se passe
ailleurs effectivement on a beaucoup pas
endre de ce que les autres font arrêtons
de penser qu'on est les seuls à inventer
tout merci beaucoup écoutez le temps
écoulé est là alors il me reste à vous
présenter une brève
bibliographie manuel Vals vous avez
publié le courage guider leur pas 12
destins face à l'Histoire en deux mots
ces 12 destins c'est quoi les les deux
mots qui les caractérise la liberté
d'abord et le fait de ne jamais suivre
la meute c'estàd au fond chacun a un
homme une femme peuvent changer le
destin d'une communauté d'un peuple et
du monde c'est effectivement ça la
liberté comme vous le dites alors
berérénis levé le courage de la
dissidence aux éditions de
l'Observatoire c'est un livre qui met
l'accent justement sur la dissidence
quand on n'est pas d'accord pour
j'allais dire aboyer avec la meute
Nicolas bavrez démocratie contre empire
totalitaire autoritaire euh on y est là
et qui est gagnant qui est perdant et
ben ce qui est intéressant c'est que
cette année 2022 elle a été
effectivement tragique sanglante mais
qu'on a vu que et ben du côté de la
Chine en fait la Chine n'est pas
infaillible on l'a vu avec la covid et
aujourd'hui l'économie qui va mal on a
vu que la Russie n'est pas invincible on
a vu que les démocraties ça nous rejoint
notre thème que les démocraties pouvait
quand même bouger réagir même si
aujourd'hui l'issue de cette grande
confrontation est loin d'être d'être
jouée le livre s'achève par une citation
de rond Haron qui peut
peut-être résumer notre conversation
elle date de juin 39 et il disait je
crois à la victoire finale des
démocraties mais à la condition c'est
qu'elle le veuille et je crois que c'est
d en même temps ça non pour le coup
c'est à mon avis un choix assez tranché
dans une période tragique justement le
Pr primat de la liberté et le primat de
l'engagement et du combat et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on est de nouveau à
l'intérieur de nos nation comme dans
l'ordre international dans un de ces
moments où le choix cardinal c'est celui
de la défense de la liberté alors Anne
lovergan vous n'avez pas publier de
livres là pour cette émission mais vous
en préparez un sur mitteran et qui va
sortir bientôt est-ce qu'il avait du
caractère et est-ce que vous allez
parler de ça très peu très peu de
caractère François mitan oui je lui ai
fait une promesse
euh un soir de juin
1994 euh il m'a demandé euh d'écrire euh
sur ce que j'avais vu et je lui ai dit
euh bah non parce que tout le monde va
faire euh mitteran et moi ou d'ailleurs
moi et mitteran dans le l'ordre qui va
bien et je ne me livrerai pas à ça et il
m'a dit mais si mais si mais non mais
vous le ferez pas tout de suite
faites-le dans 20 ans dans 25 ans et
bien voilà je le fais c'est une ça
s'appelle la promesse puisque j'ai fait
cette promesse et je joli titre et je
vais non pas raconter moi et mitan mais
mitan ce que j'en ai vu et comme c'était
un quelqu'un d'assez complexe alors avec
de l'autorité
ça une fois qu'une décision était prise
c'était pas une base de négociation pour
d'autres personnes mais il écoutait
beaucoup avant
sur comme si quelqu'un assez complexe en
fait je je raconte des facettes et puis
bah chacun refera son mitéran à part
voilà de ces différents témoignages je
rappelle que ce livre sera publié en
janvier 2024 chez Grasset alors Julien
Aubert vous avez publié Emmanuel le faux
prophète B évidemment c'est un Emmanuel
qui a rien à voir avec le nôre ou c'est
de celui-là c'est le même c'est le même
ah c'est c'était l'idée que les gens en
2017 ont découvert ce personnage
scintillant et ont souvent vu la
communication quielle est avec et je dis
dirais l'espoir de quelqu'un qui venait
rénover la vie politique sans regarder
son programme ses idées et je lui avait
écrit une lettre le jour de son élection
en lui disant que c'était une lettre
ouverte que c'était fantastique pour lui
mais que le jour où les gens
réaliseraient là où il veut amener le
pays je crains que il le déteste et que
la violence traverse son quinquena et je
l'avais mis en garde sur le fait que les
électeurs de Marine Le Pen reviendraient
étaient parti par la porte mais
reviendrai par la fenêtre sous une autre
manière donc c'est un livre d'analyse
pour expliquer pourquoi je ne suis pas
macroniste et pourquoi c'est l'inverse à
mon avis de ce qu' a été le golisme
merci alors je voudrais rappeler un
ouvrage que je trouve
important de Henry Kissinger l'ordre du
monde chez pluriel évidemment c'est du
Kissinger c'est-à-dire que c'est
brillant il parle de l'ordre du monde
comme certains parlent de leur goût pour
la cuisine ou les voyages il me reste à
vous remercier Madame messieurs
d'avoir animé mes côtés cette émission
je voudrais remercier l'équipe de LCP
qui est toujours là et fidèle et
compétente
pour faire de ces émissions des moments
de débat et avant de nous quitter je
voudrais vous soumettre ce jugement ou
cette pensée d'Arnaud Tessier il y a un
contraste saisissant entre une fonction
présidentielle omniprésente et une forme
d'impuissance et de
[Musique]
résignation